this is Sarah guide oh and not only is
she going to give you an amazing talk
about clustering she got her degree this
morning her master's from Ann Arbor and
information sciences and she's about to
give you an a really amazing talk on i'm
gonna guess maybe two hours of sleep
okay so without any further ado alright
so on this is the repo or it's not up
here it's up there but it's not up here
okay
alright so this is the repo for the
materials for this talk it's actually
going to be more of a talk instead of a
tutorial because there were so many
things I wanted to tell you about it
wasn't sure how to pack them into 40
minutes and if in a 40 minute tutorial
but if you really want to follow along
there's an eye Python notebook in this
with basically like all the code that I
talked about today it's very messy and
it's not very awesome but I will make it
awesome later so clone at your own risk
alright so I want to talk to you about
k-means clustering the scikit-learn
because i think right now that's
probably my favorite machine learning
algorithm a little bit about me um like
Cindy just said i graduated from the
university of michigan today which is
which is great so glad to be done in a
couple of weeks i will be joining us
start up in new york city called Rihanna
me as a data scientist and I I like to
be really involved with the Python
community i created the ann arbor pi
ladies chapter and if you're on twitter
i'm also on twitter and i love Twitter
so tweet at me it's my twitter handle
Sarah underscore guide oh okay so um I
mean just today I'm going to get really
in depth with what the k-means
clustering algorithm is how it works
when you should use it and then I'll
show you a very basic implementation of
it and then implementing it with some
tune parameters and we'll we'll compare
those results and just to see the how
how good the different tunings are um I
do want to mention that my talk assumes
that you have at least some basic
knowledge of machine learning hopefully
you attended Porsche stock prior prior
to this one so you know what's going on
with that um I don't really explain
basic concepts too much so yeah just let
you know I'm so just to review
clustering is a form of unsupervised
data or I'm sorry unsupervised machine
learning and um it's useful for when
your data is unlabeled and you don't
know what you're looking for the way
that clustering works is it splits
observations into groups so that
observation is in the same group are
more similar to each other than they are
to those and other groups and this is
done by some sort of distance metric
like the Euclidean metric or the
Manhattan distance metric and clustering
is is really useful for exploring your
day your data especially if you don't
know what you're looking for and there
are there are many different kinds of
clustering algorithms and there are
actually a lot of variations on the
k-means clustering algorithm but I'm
just going to talk about that one today
so um k-means clustering formally is a
method of vector quantization and it
participations of the space and 24 are
noise cells and basically separate
samples into end groups of equal
variance and this works by dividing up a
set of points where each group is
represented by its centroid point which
in k-means clustering are the k initial
clusters you choose so you choose the
initial clusters for the clustering
algorithm and it uses the Euclidean
distance metric and it also works to
within these clusters minimize the
within clusters sum of squares so the
way that this works is basically a
process of iterative refinement there
are three basic steps the first step is
you choose your your K clusters you
choose however many initial clusters you
want to start with and then iterates
over the next two steps which are
assignment and update this in the
assignment step observations are
assigned to the clusters their most
similar to then in the update step the
cluster Center is recalculated to the
mean of the new cluster based in the
assignment so the cluster Center will
move and and then it reassigns the
observations again to the clusters of
their most similar to and then
recalculate the cluster Center it'll
move again basically does this over and
over again until convergence has been
reached meeting at the point the the
observation to longer move around in the
cluster centers will no longer move
around so this is what this looks like
so um the top right there the top left
and right that's the assignment step you
have your observations and you initially
sign them to starting clusters here we
have read a blue and green cluster and
then in the update step on the on the
bottom left there you can see the
cluster Center is basically recalculate
in and then the observations are
reassigned on the bottom right there so
we have three red points instead of two
red point we have five green points and
so on and this this will go on again
until convergence convergence has been
reached so k-means clustering as some is
pretty good for large amounts of data it
scales pretty well it's efficient
because you are choosing the clusters
and it will always converge so its
benefits are also sometimes its
disadvantages so um if you choose the
wrong k things can maybe not make so
much sense as we'll see you later and
the it usually converges to the local
minimum which is locally with it like
near that cluster the minimum value but
but may not be the global minimum so may
not be the minimum value in the data set
which can be good or bad depending on
what you're trying to do so k-means
clustering is good for normally
distributed data non normally
distributed data can really skew the
results because we're using a euclidean
distance metric salt and you also want
to use it when you have a large number
of samples and also not too many
clusters which sort of is to your own
interpretation with too many clusters is
but generally works better for fewer
numbers of clusters it's also more
efficient which is um which is why you
choose K and it's also good for when
your data can be measured in a linear
fashion so non normally um non data that
can't be separated in a linear fashion
may require another method like a kernel
trick or something like that ah so
Before we jump into demonstrating this
let me say a few words about
scikit-learn so scikit-learn hopefully
you ten of that talk previous this one
is my machine learning module of choice
it's a an open source project that's
constantly
development there's a lot of community
support for which is really cool it's
built on top of numpy and scifi so you
can use it in conjunction with those
modules which I will also do in a bit it
has a lot of built-in data sets that you
can mess around with for seeing how the
different algorithms work it's very
comprehensive of the different
algorithms and there are a lot of
tutorials and resources out there for
actually learning scikit-learn so this
is just the basic fitting a model
process in some pseudocode here so we
set a model equal to an estimator object
it's going to be our k-means algorithm
and then an unsupervised learning you
fit that model to your data and you just
your data is your data set and
supervised learning you would use the
labels as another parameter for like
classification but not not in a k-means
clustering so inside KITT learned
k-means is efficient and fast you pick
the number of clusters to start with and
the algorithm finds those initial
centroids and a really cool thing you
can do is you can run clustering jobs in
parallel which I haven't done too much
with but it for large-scale data it
looks like it would be pretty good so
before I show you this song on my data
set let me say a few words about that in
data set so i took this data set from
the university of california irvine
machine learning repository website it's
a really great website with a lot of
different data sets they have oh I don't
know a lot and um they tell you what
machine learning tasks are good for like
regression or um clustering so the one
that I chose for today because it looked
kind of fun was the individual household
power consumption data set which
basically records household Parkins
consumption and the data set has about
two million instances i'm not using all
of them because um it was it was making
certain things run really slowly for the
purposes of creating this but um
some of the different features in this
data set global active power which is
household global minute averaged active
power in kilowatts global reactive power
which is household global minute
averaged reactive power in kilowatts
voltage which is meant average volt
voltage in volts global intensity
household global minute average Korean
intensity and then sub metering won his
kitchen to his laundry room and three is
water heater air conditioner and what
these things really mean I don't know
because I don't know anything about
power consumption so so let's just
explore our data set so let's just first
throw this data into a k-means estimator
with the defaults and see what happens
so we create our k-means object k means
equals K means and then we fit it to our
values so let's see what this stood so a
few notes I ran some principal component
analysis on this to to get it down into
two dimensions so i can better visualize
it this is what we get though so the y
texts are the centers are the centered
clusters of those initial eight
centroids and eight is the the default
number of clusters you get when you just
pass in a dataset to the estimator and
this is great kind of interesting kind
of looks useful but maybe we can do
better so let's talk about tuning some
of the parameters of this algorithm um
it has eight different parameters that
you can turn you can tune n clusters is
basically choosing k the number of
clusters you want to choose max
iterations the the maximum number of
iteration iteration that will go through
those assign assignment and update steps
in a single run let's see the end jobs
parameter is um when you can you can say
if you want to run it in parallel or not
so I'm actually not going to talk about
all of these because a would be would be
a lot so I'm going to talk about and
cluster
isn't how to choose K and also the init
parameter which is basically how you
choose to assign those clusters so let's
start with the number of clusters so as
you might have guessed um choosing k is
the most important part of k-means
clustering because if you if you do it
wrong your results aren't going to mean
much um there are there are different
methods there are a lot of different
others for doing this in machine
learning there are usually a lot of
different methods for doing a lot of
different things and it's impossible to
talk about all of them in 40 minutes so
three interesting ones you can graph the
the percentage of variance explained
against different values of K and at
some point adding more more values or
higher values of K will stop
significantly explaining the variance
you can use an information criterion and
this will determine the goodness of fit
for your estimator you can also use
cross validation which much like using
cross-validation to test how accurate
your model is you can use it to test
different values of K I'm going to focus
on that first one though graphing the
variance because I think it's really
interesting so unfortunately there is no
built-in function inside KITT learn to
graph the variance so um kind of to make
up your own so we can use um CyHi numpy
it's figured out ah I'm not going to
explain every single piece of the code
that I wrote here I'm just going to give
you the general overview of what I wrote
so um we we need to two functions from
sci-fi the seediest function which is a
distance computation between different
sets of observations and then the
Pietist which is the pairwise distance
computation between observations in the
same set so I get these first we want to
determine what values of K we want to
test so since eight since choosing a
initial clusters look pretty good
earlier I'm going to just test up to
choosing 14 clusters so we set that then
using a list comprehension I fit the
camis model for each of those clusters
so from 114 well 13 actually um and then
I pull out the cluster centers for each
model the the k-means estimator object
comes with different attributes and one
of them is the cluster centers attribute
so you can pull it out so that's that
last line there then we're almost done
we calculate the Euclidean distance from
each point each cluster Center we get
the total within cluster sum of squares
we get the total sum of squares and then
we get the between cluster sum of
squares and the graph that we hit this
so um this is a pretty typical graphing
variance graph here um you can see at
adding clusters at first dramatically
accounts for the variance but it
plateaus later on so let's take a look
at a few of these values so um let's
look at four just because I think that
would be interesting to look at it's
kind of near the beginning let's also
look at seven and since eight was pretty
good so seven may or may not be better
so 4 is not so good for so this is this
is why choosing k is very important
because um choosing four clusters
doesn't really represent anything
meaningful there it's just kind of why
texts in the middle sort of nothing um
seven looks a little better um a little
better let's look at eight again though
so it might be better it's hard to say
at this point so let's move on to the
other parameter I wanted to talk about
and then we'll come back to this we'll
actually combine all of them and do some
fun fun scoring stuff
ok so the init parameter is pretty
straightforward the default is k-means
plus plus which selects initial cluster
centers for the clustering in a way that
speeds up convergence you can also pass
in random and that'll choose um the the
number K observations at random from
from your data set for the initial
centroids which sounds interesting but
so might go terribly wrong and then you
can also pass in an ndarray so you can
basically assign manually cluster
centers I'm going to look at the first
two though so so let's try running
k-means with n cluster sets of both
seven and then eight and then also
setting into both k-means plus plus and
then random we're going to try all the
combinations and we're going to see what
happens so on the left there that's just
our default that's what we started with
looks pretty good you know not not too
exciting on the right there though
that's we still have eight clusters but
we're setting the Internet to random
solder selecting random random
observations from your data set as our
initial cluster centers and that doesn't
look that doesn't look quite right that
the big brown section on the bottom seen
it seems a little too spread out um and
see if you could see there in the top
left-hand corner there are two why texts
that are really close together so that's
probably not a very good indicator there
so if we move on to choosing seven
clusters the the left one there is what
we what we did before it's it looks
pretty good on the right though that's
again using random for the init
parameter and again we have in the in
the top left corner there we have two
x's that are really close so maybe not
so great so you've you've done all these
tests you have all these models
and they you know they look something
look good some of them don't we can
actually test them by comparing their
silhouette scores so you you would use
this metric when you don't have the
ground truth meaning you don't have
anything to compare it to and that's
sort of the thing with clustering and
and unsupervised learning you don't
really have labels so you have to be
able to test it without knowing what
really what to compare it to so this
works by computing the mean distance
between an observation and all other
points in its cluster and then also the
mean distance between an observation and
all other points in the next nearest
cluster so it does this for each
observation and assigns it a score
between negative 1 and 1 and the closer
it is to 1 the better fit that that
cluster is for that particular
observation so in scikit-learn the
silhouettes core function computes this
and then takes the the mean of all of
the silhouette coefficient for all of
the observations getting closer to 1 the
better the fit um this scoring method
takes a really long time to run it's not
very efficient um i think i had about i
think i have 20,000 instances i took
twenty thousand instances out of the
much larger dataset and it took a good
like five minutes to run but it is
useful so here are scores you can see
for eight clusters with k-means plus
plus as in it we get um we get a pretty
good score we had a you know a point
eight one there eight clusters with our
random selection of initial cluster
centers is not very good at all in fact
it's the it's probably the it is it is
the worst one of the bunch seven
clusters with with camis plus plus is ok
and again seven clusters with random
though
that's a good so in this case the
default wins so what does this tell us
though tells us that patterns exist
which is really useful especially if you
don't know what's going on and also
groups of similar observations exist so
there's something going on where within
our data set things are similar to each
other which can be really useful
sometimes the default work sometimes
they don't really just depends on the
data that you're working with and
finally we need more exploration um
there are other parameters there are
other other methods of choosing k so few
tips are clustering is a good way to
store the data not to not it's not a way
to absolutely say this is what's going
on but it's a good way to get in there
and see okay here are interesting things
that I want to investigate next it's
always good to remember that intuition
fails in high dimensions so especially
if you have very high dimensions so I'm
using something like dimensionality
reduction can really help that and
especially um being able to visualize
what's going on is is really helpful you
can use this in combination with other
models you could run this sort of
algorithm determine okay I have eight
separate groups I'm going to label these
as eight separate groups and then turn
it into a classification algorithm or
something like that and then also
knowing your data is really important so
knowing what's going on um you'll be
able to make the the best judgments
about what parameters to tune and what
algorithms use so um there's a lot of
great materials out there the
scikit-learn documentation is really
good highly recommended their tutorials
on there there are a lot of resources
for machine learning data sets out there
there's the as I mentioned before the
University of California Irvine machine
learning repository website which is
that first link there in the datasets
section
um really great very comprehensive and
also ml data torgus is pretty good
there's some overlap but um there
there's also some unique stuff and then
um found this really cool blog the other
day that walked through some of this
stuff data science lab so yeah check it
out and finally um contact me i'm on
twitter i'm on linkedin github hopefully
I will be able to make the materials for
today a little less messy and more
thorough and then yeah you can learn
about this all you want so that's all I
have for you um let me know if you have
any questions oh good they have a mic
for the questions when he did the
dimensionality reduction was that also
sort of helping your intuition that
there were cluster is there because if
you tried pca to only two dimensions and
it was just noise it would you wouldn't
see clusters hmm yeah I think yeah I
think um doing that sort of thing is
also a very important first step and
sort of a seeing what's going on and and
yeah reducing the noise so I would say
yes definitely so you would mention that
k-means clustering is really designed
with the assumption that your data is
normally distributed what kinds of
transformations do you do when it's not
hmm well um if it's not normally
distributed I would probably use
something different so there's um you
can actually combine colonel tricks with
k-means clustering so sort of like how
SVM you're able to non-linearly separate
vector spaces you could use you can you
can combine colonel tricks with k-means
clustering i haven't done too much of
that but um that that would be a thing
you could do um yeah ah come talk to me
we can find more few things nice catch
thanks so with I think they'll think
really high dimensional data you know
you want to visualize the clusters but
to PCA vectors might not be enough to
really get the whole sense of the data
have you ever found what are you doing
those kind of cases where you know two
vectors may only explain thirty percent
so you don't really want to base your
decisions visually or whatnot right um
so I really only did that for the
purposes of this talk if i were really
doing it i would really you know i would
really try and figure out what the best
you know what the best number of
components is and visualization is not
my strongest suit so in terms of
visualizing it i'm not sure but um if I
you know if I was doing this in a real
life situation I wouldn't just you know
willy-nilly picked two I would I would
you know do feature extraction and you
know really figure out what would be the
best number of components so I guess
that's not a great answer but it's all I
got
any other questions this is your chance
that's a great question um my question
was coming down let this slide somewhere
I will put them on SlideShare
immediately and then I will tweet the
link so incentive to follow me on
Twitter and all of these are being
recorded so they're going to be
accessible to people oh there you go
anybody else okay can we also thank
Sarah for staying awake long enough so
we are done a little bit early um I
think there's something else after this
and I can't remember what it is uh there
are drinks in the city so if you are not
aware you should have been sent an email
that tells you the zipa fun I'm saying
that wrong I apologize is sponsoring a
meet-up up in San Francisco you do need
to go back to that email and register
you do have to have an event right
ticket to get into that and otherwise we
are having another event here on the
campus tomorrow after all of the
sessions so that's going to be here and
why don't you guys start wrapping up and
we'll start getting you guys escorted to
the next place you need to go thanks
and